ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى متابعه هذه التغطيه
لتطورات في السودان اذا يوم سادس من
اشتباكات السودان ولا حل بعد لحوف الافق
قطن جديده مثل غيرها هشه لم يلتزم اي طرف
بالهدنه الجديده التي تنتهي بعد ساعه من
الان لتعود الاشتباكات دون ان تحقق الهدنه
اهدافها الاساسيه الانسانيه طبعا حرب على
الارض بين البرهان وحماتي وسرعه نقله حتى
على وسائل الاعلام العالميه فكلاهما خرج
ليتحدث مع صحيفه
وكلاهما يكيلو الاتهامات للاخر البرهان
تهما قوه الدعم السريع بانها خرجت عن
سيطره حميتي والاخير توعد بمحاكمه قائد
القوات العسكريه
[موسيقى]
وفي اخر التطورات مشاهدينا اكد الجيش
السوداني ان الهدنه الانسانيه لا تعني
التفاوض مع قوات الدعم السريع مشددا على
انه لا تفاوض على الاستسلام الكامل واوضح
بيان للجيش ان الموقف العملياتيه مستقر
حتى الان مضيفا ان حدث هجمات قوات الدعم
السريع تراجعت على محيط القياده العامه
واضاف الناطق باسم الجيش ان قوات او
القوات الجويه وجه ضربات مركزه على ارتال
عسكريه للدعم السريع كانت في طريقها الى
الخرطوم اسفرت عن تدمير قوتين لدعم السريع
على طريقي التحدي وبارا وحواري مائه عربه
في المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني بمهاجمه قواتها في ام درمان
مشيره الى تمكنها من التصدي للهجوم على
تمركزاتها غرب المدينه واضافت القوات
العناصرها اسقطت مروحيتين للقوات الجويه
السودانيه كما اكدت على ما وصفته بالتزام
قواتها بالبقاء في مواقعها ووقف اطلاق
النار منذ اعلان الهدنه
الى ذلك كان اذان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي ادان استمرار العنف في السودان
اليوم السادس داعيا طرف يسرع لوقف الاعمال
العدائيه فورا مؤكدا على تاييده لتطلعات
الشعب السوداني في الانتقال الديمقراطي
السلمي
المفاوض الاوروبي لاداره الازمات يعني
هو الاخر القتال الدائره في السودان داعيا
طرف يسرع الى انهاء التصعيد والوقف الفوري
لاطلاق النار وقال لنارتشيتش في حسابه على
تويتر ان هناك تقارير مروعه عن وقوع خسائر
في الارواح بالسودان لاسيما في صفوف
المدنيين
في الاسنان كانت افتت منظمه الصحه
العالميه بمقتل 330 شخصا وباصابه
3200 اخرين جراء الاشتباكات في السودان
ودعت الصحه العالميه جميع الاطراف في
السودان لهدنه انسانيه لسماح للمواطنين
بالحصول على الرعايه الطبيه كما اكدت
المنظمه انها ستجلب المزيد من التجهيزات
الطبيه لدى السماح بذلك مشيره الى النقص
الحاد في امدادات المياه والوقود في
المنشات الصحيه بالسودان مضيفه ان نحو 20
مستشفى خرجات عن الخدمه بسبب الهجمات او
نقص الموارد
حرب تاميه دفعت النظام الصحيه في السودان
الى حافه الانهيار لتصبح الازمه ازمتين
تزيد من ماساه الشعب السوداني الذي اتخن
بالجراح في بلد لم يعرف الاستقرار التام
منذ عقود وهو الان ضحيه السيناريو الاسود
ارقام صادمه لعدد المستشفيات التي اصبحت
خارج الخدمه في ذروه احتياج المواطنين لها
سبعون في المئه من المرافق الصحيه اوقفت
عن العمل او اجبرت على الاغلاق بحسب نقابه
اطباء السودان فمن اصل 74 مستشفى في
العاصمه والولايات التي تقع بالقرب من
مناطق الاشتباك يوجد 52 مستشفى منها اصبحت
خارج الخدمه تماما بعد الاشتباكات الاخيره
تسعه مستشفيات منها تعرضت القصف الشديد
وتسعه عشر مستشفى اخر تعرضت للاخلاء
القصري ما يعني وجود
مستشفى فقط في المنطقه تعمل بشكل كامل او
جزئي وهي الاخرى مهدده بالاغلاق في اي
لحظه بسبب انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
وانعدام الادويه وغياب الكوادر الصحيه
فهذه المرافق الطبيه تعمل بالحد الادنى من
الامكانيات والحد الاقصى من انعدام الامن
حولها
نظام الرعايه الصحيه في السودان يمكن ان
ينهر تماما تحتاج المستشفيات الى موظفين
اضافي وتحتاج الى امدادات اضافيه وتحتاج
الى امدادات دم اضافي هناك تقريبا هجوم
عسكري على عدد من المؤسسات الصحيه هناك
يعني هجوم على سيارات اسعاف وبها مرضى
وبها عاملين صحيين وعلى الرغم من تصاعد
التحذيرات الدوليه من كارثه انسانيه
وانهيار القطاع الصحي في البلاد الا ان
القتال لازال يتواصل في العاصمه السودانيه
ومدن اخرى
في هذه الاثناء كان اكد الجيش السوداني
انه تمكن من دحر قوات الدعم السريع في
مدينه الاوبيض بولايه شمال كردفان حيث نشر
لقطات لمشاهد من الاشتباكات
باننا الان داخل هذا المطار وداخل القاعده
العسكريه العملياتيه في مدينه مروي هذا هو
برج المراقبه الرئيس للقاعده وللمطار هذا
البرج الذي كنا يوم امس في هذه النقطه وقد
عكسنا حجم الضرر الذي لحق به
هذه الاجهزه
الاجهزه التواصل والاتصال
يبدو انها مدمره بالكامل
واستقبال الطائرات
عبر اجهزه الرادار محمد بالنسبه
هنا هذه الصور لهذه الاجهزه اللاسلكيه
يبدو انها خارج الخدمه مع من الان
كالنتيجه اشتباكات حصلت في هذه المواقع
تدمير للعناصر الدعم السريع ربما التي
كانت موجوده قبل انسحابها ماذا يقول
هو مؤكد خالد
المطروحه الان بان الاشتباكات كانت عنيفه
كل ما يحدث من ضرر هو نتيجه لهذا
الاشتباكات نتيجه للقصف العنيف الذي شهدته
هذه المنطقه
هذا ما يمكن ان نؤكد عليه بان الضرر وقع
نتيجه لعمل عسكري كانت هذه المنطقه من
المطار
مسرحا
وكانت ارضيه لكل العمليات العسكريه القصف
المدفعي القصف العنيف
حجم الضرر هذا الدمار الذي لحق بالمطار
لحق بالقاعده
لحق بهذا البرج لهذه القاعده وهذا المطار
الذي يمثل احد اهم المطارات في المنطقه
الاقليميه لانه يطل على الاتجاه الشمالي
للسودان على حدود السودان مع دوله مصر
منهم مباشره يمكن ان يتم التنسيق كما فعل
مسبقا الجيش السوداني مع عدد من جيوش
الدول في المنطقه الاقليميه
ايضا يعتبر هذا المطار بديلا لمطار
الخرطوم الدولي اذا ما حدثت اي متغيرات في
مطار الخرطوم يتم الاستعانه بهذا المطار
ومشاهدينا مروي هي من ابرز اسماء المدن
السودانيه التي تصدرت عناوين الاخبار خلال
الايام الماضيه التقرير الثاني يعرفنا
اكثر على هذه المدينه وخاصه على اهميتها
نتابع
محاور عده للنزاع في السودان من ابرزها ما
يدور في العاصمه لكن الاعين تتوجه ايضا
لمنطقه اخرى الى اكبر ولايات السودان
الولايه الشماليه التي برز من بين مدنها
بشكل لافت مروي الواقعه على بعد 350
كيلومترا شمال العاصمه الخرطوم المدينه
ذات اهميه عسكريه كبيره ازدادت مع الصراع
الحالي بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع جل
التركيز صب على مطار المدينه بالجانبين
المدني والعسكري وتضاربت الانباء حول
الجانب المسيطر عليه الى ان اعلن الجيش عن
اعاده السيطره على مطار مروي المطار يعتبر
قاعده جويه مسانده ومنطقه تمركز بديله
للقواعد العسكريه الاخرى في السودان ويغطي
مطارها العمليات الجويه في شمال السودان
وشرقه وغربه اهميه مطار مروي تتاتى من
كونه احد اكبر المطارات في افريقيا فهو
يقع على مساحه 18 كيلوم ترا وهو مصمم
لاسيعاب هبوط واقلاع الطائرات الضخمه
بمهبط طائرات بطول حوالي اربعه كيلو مترات
وعرض 60 مترا وفي مطار مروي ومحيطه تنتشر
قوات الفرقه تسعه عشر التابعه للجيش
السوداني المسؤوله عن حمايه المرافق
الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع زمينا من مروي مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار اهلا بك معنا
وفيتنا بتفاصيل خاصه بمطار مروي والاضرار
التي تعرض لها المطار حدثنا عما لم يحمله
هذا التقرير من تفاصيل اضافيه قادره ان
تضعنا في اطار التطورات من عندك
لم تعكسه الصوره ولم يتح لنا عبر الزمن ان
نغطي من معلومات ومن تداعيات لهذه
العمليات العسكريه هو الاستمرار المتواصل
من قبل سلاح المهندسين وسلاح المهندسين هو
احد الاسلحه او الوحدات التي
تنضم دائما من قبل الجيش السوداني للاسهام
في المسائل المتعلقه بالاوضاع وبالجوانب
الهندسيه هذا السلاح الان يعمل ااا منذ
امس ومنذ ساعات متواصله لحصر الضرر
المتعلق بالاليات التي تاثرت خلال هذه
الاشتباكات ويعمل ايضا على معالجه الاجسام
هنالك اجسام غير منفجره ما زالت في ارضيه
مطار مروي وما زالت داخل القاعده اجسام
تتعلق بالذخائر الغير منفجره هنالك ايضا
معها القوات نزار
سلاح المهندسين له من الامكانيات ما يؤهله
ويمكنه من التعامل مع هذه الاجسام وخطوره
هذه الاجسام
تكمن في انه اذا لم ينظف المطار بشكل كامل
عبر الاجهزه المختصه وعبر سلاح المهندسين
وعبر الجهات المختصه من الجيش لتنظيفه لم
يتمكن الطيران المدني من الدخول والاقلاع
والهبوط في هذه المنطقه لابد من تسليم
المطار تسليما كاملا نظيفا ليس فيه اي
مؤثرات سالبه وليس فيه اي اجسام يمكن ان
تحدث ضررا اذا ما اعاد اذا ما عاد المطار
الى عمله كما كان في السابق هي مهمه عسيره
لان المساحه شاسعه نحو 18 كلم مربع
اجسام غير منفجره في عديد المواقع داخل
هذه القاعده هذا
يستدعي زمنا يستدعي امكانيات للجيش يستدعي
ايضا ظرفا زمنيا يمكن هذه الايام من ان
تحدث مسحا كاملا وشاملا وهل بدا العمل
نزار لانه في المقابل كانت هناك معلومات
مفادها كذلك بان هناك انتظار من الجهات
الامميه لتحيد المطارات لتمكين
المنظمات المعنيه لايصال المساعدات هل
هناك عمل جاري في هذه الاثناء على
محاوله على الاقل تامين هذه المطارات
يعني على الاقل الان القوات المس
لحه استعمل على هذه الخطوات تعمل على
اجلاء ما تبقى من اليات ومن خسائر ومن
عتاد
خلال الاشتباكات تعمل ايضا عبر فرقها على
تنظيف
المواقع من الاجسام الغير منفجره تعمل
ايضا على حصر الاضرار المتعلقه بالمرافق
الخدميه للقاعده وللمطار تعمل ايضا على
وضع التصور لكيفيه عوده ما تضرر من اجسام
ومن مرافق الحديث عن برج المراقبه هذا
البرج الذي كنا فيه ظهر هذا اليوم اتضرر
بشكل جزئي كلي في بعض المواقع اي في
الاتصالات البعض يعمل والبعض لا يعمل ضمرت
ايضا بشكل
جزئي هنالك اجهزه ايضا مهمه عرفنا بانها
اجهزه للتواصل مع
الطائرات عندما تكون في طور التحليق او في
الهواء ايضا التضر بعض الشيء المسؤولون
والمعنيون بالمطار يقولون بانهم يسعون الى
ان يكون هنالك تقرير [__] حجم الضرر بشكل
كلي ويقدم لاداره الطيران او في الجهات
الرسميه العليا في الخرطوم لمعرفه كيف
يبدا عمل المطار وبالتاكيد نحن ندرك ان
الاوضاع الان اوضاع معقده
الاوضاع صعبه ومعقده هذا فيما يخص المطار
نزار ولكن تبعنا كذلك جولتك في اسواق
مدينه مروي وبحسب الصوره على الاقل الوضع
بدا يعود تدريجيا وكانها عادي
حدثنا اكثر عن هذه الصوره هل هي فقط تخص
السوق هل هي فقط صوره ستقتصر على فتره هذه
الهدنه ام ان الحياه فعليا بدات تعود شيئا
فشيئا في مدينه مروي
الحياه فعليا وعم بدات تعود بشكل
روتيني الى مدينه مروي خاصه وانهم تاكد
لهم بان الجيش
بسط السيطره على المطار وعلى المناطق
الجنوبيه هذه الاخبار اندفعت كثير من
المواطنين خاصه الذين غادروا المدينه خلال
الايام الماضيه بالعوده الى مدينتهم
بالعوده الى منازلهم خرجوا صباح وظهر هذا
اليوم الى الاسواق للتبضع ولشرائح
احتياجاتهم استعدادا
للعيد الذي سيقبل بعد ساعات من الان
مبدئيا المدينه هادئه حاله الاستقرار هي
المنشوده وهي التي يطالب المواطنون ان
تستمر هم يقولون بانهم اخف ضررا مما يحدث
في الخرطوم وان قلوبهم يعني مليئه بالحزن
لما يشاهدونه ولما يسمعونه من اخبار
ويدعون الله في هذه الايام المباركات ان
تنجلي ما يقولون بانها غمه
استظل بها السودانيون خلال الايام الماضيه
لكن نقول بان مروي الان هاديه مستقر نسبيا
الامور تمضي نحو التهدئه
من خلال تغطيتك اود شكرا جزيل الشكر نزار
بقداوي مراسل العربيه من مروي
مشاهدينا حرب السلطه او حرب الجنرلين كما
بات توصف شرف يومها الخامس على الانتهاء
وفيما الاشتباكات تتواصل تتزايد المخاوف
من توسع رقعه النزاع ليدق اسوار الدول
المجاوره ويزعزع انها نتابع
حرب الازقه والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا
فشيئا لحاره مجاوره واخره لها طالما ان
الجنرالين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها شخص
اقتصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لحق بالركب ولم يفته القطار دوله
شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه والعسكريه
كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا ولبنان حيث
يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع بالسياده وحق
تقرير المصير اي دول ديجوري وفق القانون
الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على الجانب الاخر
من القائمه دول مسلوبه القرار ومهمشه بحكم
الواقع او ديفاكتو
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه السودان
يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي يربط اهم
ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب وقناه السويس
ما يزيد مغريات الدوله الذهبيه الكثيره في
عيون دول كبرى بينها روسيا وتركيا فحلم
القاعده البحريه هناك تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرالين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول فبايد ليست
متوفره حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا
وتايوان حل لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه
الخجوله قبل اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي
خساره الطرفين وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من برلين
مدير برنامج افريقيا في المجلس الاوروبي
للعلاقات الخارجيه سيد مرسي اهلا بك معنا
مبدئيا كيف تدافعون هذه التطورات وخاصه
هذه الهدنه وان تخللتها الشبكات ولكن يبدو
بانها مكنت بعض المناطق من تحقيق هدوء ولو
كان هدوء حاضر نتحدث عن مروي مثلا
اللي الصوره فيها غير الصوره الموجوده في
الخرطوم كيف تتابعون هذه التطورات مبدئيا
شكرا جزيلا
اعتقد ان الحاله لا تزال مثيره للقلق
فالجزء الاكثر صعوبه من هذا الصراع هو ان
العمليات القتاليه تدور في مناطق حضاريه
بالخرطوم وهذا سبب يعزى الى ان قوات الدعم
السريع
لديها قواعد صغيره متنقله ومنتشره في كافه
ارجاء الخرطوم
وبغيت
محاربه هذه المجموعه فان الجيش النظامي
لابد له من شن عمليات داخل الخرطوم ولهذا
السبب
فان
العمليات التي تواجه
كافه الجهود الانسانيه حتى اللحظه تمنع
بصعوبات كثيره وكذلك العاملون في هذا
المجال يواجهون صعوبات كبيره
حدثنا اكثر لو سمحت عن هذه الصعوبات سيد
ماهر في صعوبات تتعلق بايصال المساعدات
بادخالها للسودان بتوزيعها ما هي تفاصيل
هذه الصعوبات
بكل تاكيد
هذا صراع صعب
وحتى اللحظه
وانك كافه المؤن المطلوبه
لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه غير متوفره
وكلما طال امد هذا الصراع فاننا سوف نجد
ان هناك بعض القواعد التي يجب ان يتم
تاسيسها والتي يؤمل من الطرفين ان يتم
العمل على احترامها وحتى الان فانها حرب
مفتوحه ومن الصعب في ظل تلك الظروف ان يتم
تنظيم
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه بطريقه امنه
وسالمه ما يحدث في الفتره الحاليه هو هي
عمل هي
عمليات تقديم الرعايه طبيه
بطريقه غير منظمه
وهذا بسبب الوضع الذي قد يتجلى في الفتره
القادمه سيد مرسي بحسب تقييمكم للوضع ما
هي المساعدات المستعجله اكثر من غيرها في
هذه الاسنان
اعتقد ان هناك اناس كثر قد تعرضوا
للاصابات بسبب عمليات القتال لذا ما ترونه
هو انه هناك حاجه
للطوارئ الطبيه اي بمعنى المستشفيات
والاسعافات الاوليه وهذه المساعدات وهي
تختلف عن المساعدات التي تتعلق بالجفاف
التي
تكون مرتبطه صوره بها باشخاص في مخيمات
للاجئين
ثقافه الناس الذين يعيشون في الخرطوم
والمناطق الحضاريه محاصرون وهم بحاجه الى
اطباء ومساعدات اوليه فتلك هي انواع
المساعدات التي تحظى بالاولويه الان
من الجهه التي تساعدكم من الجهه التي
تتفاعلون معها تتواصلون معها لتمكينكم من
الوصول الى كل هذه الاحياء
بكل تاكيد انا بصوره شخصيه
عملته في السودان لسنوات طويله او لعقد من
الزمن واعلموا الناس وكافه اطراف الصرع
واتحدث مع هؤلاء
الذين يعيشون في المخيمات المدنيه وكذلك
الاناس العاديين الذين يواجهون تلك الازمه
الانسانيه
طيب سيد مررفي هل لديكم مخاوف الجهه
الامميه مثلا تتحدث عن مخاوف من ان يتحول
الوضع في داخل السوداني الى وضع اكثر
كارثيه ما هي مخاوفكم ليس فقط فيما يتعلق
بالمخيمات كنت تحدثني عن المخيمات وافهم
بانكم تتابعون كذلك هذا الموضوع ولكن مع
تطورات السودان مع هذه الازمه الاخيره ما
هي مخاوفكم المستقبليه
اعتقد ان هناك
نوعان من انواع المخاوف الرئيسيه اولا
انتشار رقعه هذا الصراع
فهاتان للمجموعتان الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع الجنرالان
قد يدفعان بجهات اخرى في السودان
للسير على نفس المنوال وكما يدرك
المشاهدون السودان يوجد فيها حركات مسلحه
كثيره وحتى اللحظه غير منخرطه في القتال
وكانت هناك مساعع لاجراء عمليه سلميه
والتوصل لحل انتقالي سلمي لكن من المحتمل
بانه اذا ما اشتدت وتيره ذلك الصراع بانها
قد تدفع
بتلك الجهه المسلحه الاخرى لسير على نفس
الاتجاه الامر الاخر هو الدول المجاوره
للسودان التي قد ايضا تدخل في هذا الصراع
وتصبح بحاله غير مستقره ما نسعى ان نفعله
وتحاشيه كاسره دوليه هو انتشار هذا الصراع
نود بدلا من ذلك ان نرى احتواء لهذا
الصراع اي بمعنى اخر كافه الجهات فاعله
سواء كانت داخل السودان او كانت في من
خلال الدول المجاوره يتوجب عليها ان تبقى
على خط الحياد وعلينا ان نساعدها عن تبقى
على ذلك من خلال تقديم المساعدات الضروريه
ورحت الفكره وشكرك جزيل الشكر يا سياده
ميرسي مدير برنامج افريقيا في المجلس
الاوروبي للعلاقات الخارجيه كنت معنا من
برلين ومشاهدينا نتابع دائما هذه التغطيه
نتابع هذه الصور المباشره من الخرطوم حيث
تتصاعد اعمده الدخان بكثافه ونشير الى
اننا كنا خلال هدنه 24 ساعه
تخللتها اشتباكات متقطعه ولكنها مكنت بعض
المناطق من تثبيت حاله هدوء متفرق في بعض
المناطق من الخرطوم وكذلك في بعض المدن
ومن بينها مروي نذهب الى هذه الصور ومن ثم
نعود لاستكمال هذه التغطيه
[موسيقى]
سنبقى في متابعه هذه الصور
ونذكر ببعض الاخبار ذات الصله حيث حذرا
قياديون بقوى الحريه والتغيير السودانيه
في تصريحات لصحيفه سودان تريبيون من انس
استمرار الحرب سيؤدي الى ما وصفه بتدخل
اقليمي واسع يحول السودان الى دويلات
متنازعه ونقلت الصحيفه عن القيادي بالحريه
والتغيير ياسر عرمان قوله ان الحاله
الواحده في السودان هو تشكيل كتله مدنيه
صلبه ومتحده ضد الحرب مشددا على انه بدون
ذلك ستتمزق البلاد دون رحمه
نشر الجيش السوداني مقطع فيديو يظهر
سيطرته على قاعده
والتي تعتبر من اكبر خطوط الامداد للقوات
الدعم السريعه
[موسيقى]
لقوات الدعم الس
ريع
بعدها استلام عدد خمس عربه لاندك وعدد
واحد تنكر
قمر وكميه من الاسلحه والزخاير
من فضله في هذه الساعه
على عدد خمسه
متداول تصدعناصر دعم سريع عبر المضادات
الارضيه لطائرات حربيه تابعه للجيش
السوداني في الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
ارفع فوق
الطيران
[موسيقى]
متابعه كل هذه التطورات مع ضيفتنا من
الخرطوم ليست تحرير صحيفه التغيير رشا عوض
صيدا رشا اهلا بك معنا في الواقع نحن
نتابع تطورات ما يحدث في داخل السوداني
خاصه باننا على بعد ما يقرب عن النصف ساعه
من انتهاء الهدنه هذه الهدنه انتظرها
كثيرون خاصه لتمكين الفرق الاغاثيه من
تقديم المساعدات مبدئيا تقييمك الاولي هل
ترين بان هذه الهدنه وان تخللت اشتباكات
الا انها مكنت على الاقل من تثبيت وضع
معين قادر ان يفي بجزء من هذه الوعود
ام التحيه لك والتحيه للمشاهدين الكرام
الوضع الانساني المعقد في الخرطوم تحديدا
في المناطق التي تدور حولها الاشتباكات
يحتاج الى هضمه اضافيه يحتاج الى هضمه
طويله نسبيا لان هناك
دمار هائل لحقه بالمدينه وهناك ج وهناك
مصابون وهناك منشات مدنيه تدمرت
ولكن الشاهد ان حتى خلال الهدنه يعني لن
تتوقف
الاجتماع من ربما تكون الهدنه
الثانيه افضل حالا من الهدنه الاولى التي
انهارت في وقتها تخزي سيد رشا لانه اليوم
الثاني كانت هناك هدنه
في اليوم الثالث كانت هناك هدنه ثانيه لم
تحترمها ال 24 ساعه يبدو بانها احترمت
بطريقه
يعني متباينه بين الطرفين نحن نستمع دائما
لاطلاق النار وكذلك طويلا في الجارات في
الخرطوم رغم هذه الهدنه ونحن نتابع كذلك
استاذه رشا على الشاشه
تصاعد لدخان كثيف وهناك الشبكات مستمره
وهناك اطلاق لقذائف مدفعيه ولكن حدثتني
صيده رشا عن الوضع الصعب في داخل السوداني
فيما يتعلق
بالوضع الانساني طيب ما الذي يمكن فعله
الى جانب امكانيه تمديد هذه الهدنه تبقى
هناك ممرات غير امنه في هذا الاطار كيف
يجب ان يعمل على هذا الملف
يعني الملف الانساني في السودان بعد سته
ايام من اندلاع المواجهات يجب ان يدار
باحترافيه تتدخل فيها جهاز دوليه متخصصه
ان تكون الهدنه مثلا مراقبه من جهه مستقله
الامم المتحده الصليب الاحمر المؤسسات
المختصه بمثل هذه الامور ان يكون هناك
خطاب دولي خطاب اقليمي يضغط الطرفين
الاطراف التي تستطيع التاثير في الطرفين
تضغط على الطرفين ما داموا دخلوا في معركه
تكسير العظام هذه يعني فاضعف الايمان ان
يفتحوا الممرات الامنه للنساء والاطفال
والجرحى المحاصرين الذين لا يستطيعون
الوصول للمستشفيات
للمزعورين والمرعوبين الذين يريدون مغادره
منازلهم والتوجه الى اهلهم في الولايات
ولكنه من عدم الامان في الطريق كلما
استمرت الحرب اكثر كلما تعقد الوضع
الانساني وكل ما تصاعدت الحاجه
لهدنه لا تترك لتقديرات الطرفين وانما
تراقب من منظمات ومؤسسات مستقله طيب ولو
انه هذه الهدنه كذلك تراقبها الامم
المتحده الا انها تخللتها الشباكات طيب
سيده رشا هذا الوضع الانساني يشغل كل
الاطراف وحتى طرفي النزاع وفي التصريحات
الاخيره لطرف النزاع اكد على امكانيه
الموافقه على تثبيت هدنه انسانيه بمعنى
انه الوضع الانساني جدا حرج وهناك موافقات
مبدئيه على امكانيه تثبيت ممرات امنه ولكن
هذا لا يعني بان الاشتباكات لن تستمر طيب
سؤال المطروح كيف يستقيم الوضع بتثبيت
هدنه انسانيه مع استكمال هذه الاشتباكات
طبعا
التوقف حتى اطراف القتال نفسها
بعد فتره سوف تجد نفسها هي بحاجه للهدنه
هي اصلا الحسابات التي دفعت الى هذه الحرب
حسابات خاطئه وغير موضوعيه الطرف الذي
اشعلها كان يعتقد انها حرب خاصه وسريعه
في ساعات ولم يستمع الى الاصوات المدنيه
والاصوات الديمقراطيه التي كانت تقول ان
مجرد اندلاع الحرب معناها ان ابواب الجحيم
انفتحت على السودان وبالتالي يجب تفادي
خيار الحظ ابتداء الان لم يستمعوا الى ذلك
استمع يصلون النظام البائد
دون دفع الى هذه الحرب عبر عناصرهم في
الجيش وكما توقعنا الامور تعقدت على الارض
لم يتمكن كلا الطرفين من الحسم على
الميدان لصالحه وهما الان يشتبقون حول
المواقع الاستراتيجيه وضحت الفكره تفضلي
بالبقاء معي سيده رشا عوض عود لك بعد اعود
لك بعد قليل ينضم لنا كذلك في اطار هذه
التغطيه من جنوب الخرطومه صحفي مدثر محمد
احمد سيد مدثر اهلا بك معنا كيف يبدو
الوضع في جنوب الخرطوم خلينا مبدئيا نقف
على تطورات وتفاصيل الصوره الكامله في
جنوب الخرطوم كيف تبدو في هذه الساعات
منطقه جنوب الخرطوم خلال الهدنه خلال
الساعات الاخيره للهدمه الثالثه يبدو
الوضع اكثر استقرارا من امس في مثل هذا
التوقيت بكل تاكيد
الهدوء هو يعني ما يسيطر هناك
احساس بالامان حتى الان في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم ولذلك هناك حركه نشطه لعمليات
الشراء في المحلات التجاريه داخل الاحياء
بغيت
التزود بالمؤن الغذائيه خاصه ان الجميع
هنا فيما قبل مرحله الافطار الرمضاني
ولذلك ارى يعني ارى اماني مجموعات كبيره
من المواطنين في تزوج بالمواد التموينيه
في المحلات التجاريه ولذلك ربما تحسبا ان
الساعات التي الدقائق التي تبقى من الهدنه
الثالثه
تحسبا تحسبا بمعنى هناك مخاوف من ان تتوسع
رقعه الاشتباكات هل هناك بوادر هل هناك ما
يدفع لمثل هكذا مخاوف
من خلال استطلاعات بعض المواطنين هنا هناك
نتحدث
[موسيقى]
في هذه المحلات بهذه الكميات يقولون ان
هناك تخوف من ان هذه الهدنه اذا انتهت
ربما لم نجد فرصه اخرى في القلب ولذلك
هناك شعور طاقيه وشعور عام بان هذه الهدنه
سيعطوها اشتباك عنيف على مستوى اوسع اذا
كانت هذه الاشتباكات خلال الهدنه منخفضه
في منطقه وسط الخرطوم ومن منطقه القياده
العامه ومنطقه مطار الخرطوم فهو يتوقعون
ان تتطور هذه الاشتباكات بعد الهدنه في
منطقه جنوب الخرطوم خاصه وان خلال هذه
الهجمه بحسب المعلومات التي تحصلنا اليها
هناك تحركات لكل من قوات القوات الدعم
السريه لقوات الجيش التي دخلت الى الخرطوم
عن طريق المداخل من جنوب الخرطوم من
الناحيه الغربيه او من الناحيه الشرقيه
هناك تحركات
ولذلك يتوقعون ان تكون هناك اشتباكات
عنيفه في المستوى او في محيط منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم سواء مدفعيه
طيب اسمح لي ان اعود لك بعد حظ سيد مدثر
لنفهم كذلك طبيعه
يعني كيف يتعامل الداخل الجنوبي الخرطومي
مع كل هذه التطورات هل هناك قاعده شعبيه
لما يحدث نفهم اكثر ديموغرافيه هذه
المنطقه ولكن قبل ذلك اسمح لي ان اشير الى
هذا العاجل عن الديوان الملكي السعودي
الذي يعلن ان المحكمه العليا تؤكد ان عيد
الفطر غدا الجمعه اذا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تؤكد بان غدا هو عيد
الفطر كل عام
واهالي المملكه بالف خير وكل عام وكل
مشاهدينا ومتابعينا بالف خير على هذا
العيد يحمل هدنه ويحمل القليل على الاقل
من الهدوء داخل السودان كذلك الذي انطلقت
فيه هذه الازمه
وتطورت فيه الاحداث في الايام الاخيره نحن
نتحدث عن سادس يومنا الاشتباكات بين الدعم
السريع وقوات الجيش اعود لك سيد مدثر سيد
مدثر الديموغرافيه هذه المنطقه بمعنى
هل هناك حواظ لطرفين سواء الجيش او الدعم
مما قد
يؤكد او على الاقل يشير بانه ان تطور
الموضوع ان توسعت رقعه الاشتباكات قد
تتحول الى ما يتخوف منه الكل في داخل
السوداني وهي الحرب الاهليه
المنطقه لا لا اظن انها تحميل ما تشير او
مع شرطي اليه ما كنت اتحدث عن انه هناك
تخوفات في هذه المنطقه
ان هناك عدد من المعسكرات في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم في منطقه جبره في منطقه
جنوب السلة هذه مقرات ومعسكرات
كانت لدى القوات الدعم السريع وهي كانت
تتخذها مواقع لديها ولذلك
هذه المواقع هذه المواقع هي ربما تكون
مستهدفه خلال الفتره المقبله باعتبار انه
ربما تكون هناك التحركات خلال الفتره
الماضيه هناك يتحدث عن ان هناك قوات كانت
في حركه ذائبه في منطقه الشرق الخرطوم او
الشرق النيل في منطقه شرق ولذلك هذه
التحركات وهذه التمركزات واعاده
ما بين القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع في
هذه المنطقه بعض نهايه الهدنه ولكن لا اظن
ان هناك من في ولايه الخرطوم بشكل عام
يعني
لا اظن ان هناك من يحاول ان يكون
ماذا اطلق عليهم يعني يعني منطلقه بهذه
القوات او بتلك القوات
تفضل بالباقي معي يعود من جديد لك رشا عوض
نحن لاحظنا منذ بدايه هذه الاشتباكات بان
هناك نوع من النائبه النفس من المواطنين
حتى لا يكرر التاريخ نفسه حتى لا تتكرر
الحرب الاهليه
في نهايه الامر السودانيون هم من يتضررون
اول باول من تداعياتها هل النائب النفس من
الشعب السوداني يمكن ان يؤثر على هذه
الاشتباكات بمعنى انه قد يحجمها قد يعقد
توسعها تعتقدين
هذا هو الشيء الايجابي الان ان الشعب
السوداني
في قطاعاته المختلفه عزل هذه الحرب وهو ما
نتمنى ان يستمر الحرب يجب
ان تنحصر في سياقها الموضوعي وهو الصراع
على السلطه بين قوات الدعم السريع وبين
فصيل انقلاب من النظام البائد يستغل
القوات المسلحه
يجب ان لا نوفر حاضنه اجتماعيه وشعبيه
لاطراف القتال المختلفه حتى ينتقل الحريق
الى اوساط المواطنين وندخل في دوامه الحرب
الاهليه احد الاسباب التي تعجل بنهايه اي
حرف هي سحب المشروعيه الوطنيه والمشروعيه
السياسيه عنها
الجيش السوداني المؤسسه
له حاضنه شعبيه وهناك من يؤيده الدعم
السريع ايضا له حاضنه شعبيه في دارفور لا
نريد لهاتين الحاضنتين ان يشتبك لان الحرب
يحركه تحرقها اقماع السلطه لدى صفاء
الانقلابيه وبالتالي الشعب السوداني ليس
طرفا في هذه الحرب اود شكرك جزيلا الشكر
رشا عوض رئيسه تحرير صحيفه التغيير والشكر
كذلك لضيفي من جنوب الخرطومه صحفي مدثر
محمد احمد شكرا جزيلا على المشاركه في هذه
التغطيه نشير دائما الى هذه الصور
مشاهدينا نحن في تغطيه مستمره على شاشه
العربيه للتطورات فداخل السوداني هذه
الهدنه بعد قليل تصل بعد تقريبا ربع ساعه
تصل الى نهايتها ولكن رغم ذلك خلال هذه
الهدنه كانت هناك اشتباكات استمرت لفتره
متقاطعه البعض يتحدث عن اح تمكن بعض
اهاليها من الخروج من قضاء حاجاتهم
الاساسيه من ابتظام بعض المواد الغذائيه
والطبيه ولكن احياء اخرى ونتحدث على محيط
مثلا القياده العامه حيث تتواجد مناطق
سكنيه مهمه هذه المناطق هي المناطق الخروج
فيها او التنقل على الاقل في محيطها او
قريبا منها يبدو خطيرا لان هذه الاشتباكات
لا زالت مستمره ونحن نتابع على الشاشه هذا
الصور لدخان كثيف لاصوات لاطلاق نار وكذلك
لاصوات لاطلاق
قذائف مدفعيه في الايام الاولى من هذه
الاشتباكات كان هناك حتى استعمال واستخدام
لاسلحه ثقيله رصدناه من خلال الصور وكذلك
من خلال مراقبين واكدته حتى اطراف النزاع
فداخل السوداني ولكن اليوم لم تكن هناك
انفجارات قويه وكان هناك احترام مبدئي
الهدنه هذه الهدنه اقترحتها الجهه الامميه
ورقبتها كذلك واكدت على ان طرفي النزاع
قوات الجيش السوداني وكذلك حتى قوات الدعم
السريع كلاهما لم يلتزم بطريقه كامله بهذه
الهدنه ولكن الاطراف كذلك تبادلت
الاتهامات بخصوص خرق الهدنه كل طرف يقول
بان طرف المقابل هو الذي خرق هذه الهدنه
وفي الواقع تبادل الاتهامات اتى حتى في
اليوم الاول من بدء هذه الاشتباكات اطلاق
اول رصاصه محل تساؤل لان البعض يقول بان
قوات الدعم السريع هي تتحمل انتشارها في
مروي ولكن بعض الاخر يقول بان هذا
الانتشار تم بالاتفاق مع قوات الجيش وقوات
الجيش هي التي بدات باطلاق هذه الاشتباكات
مشاهدينا نستكمل مع بعض الاخبار ذات الصله
حيث اكدت منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
مقتل ما لا يقل عن تسعه اطفال واصابه اكثر
من 50 اخرين في الاشتباكات الدائره في
السودان واوضح بيان اليونيسيف ان العديد
من العائلات في السودان محاصره بسبب تبادل
اطلاق النار كما اجبر الالاف على مغادره
المنازل بحثا عن مكان امن كما اكدت انها
لا يمكنها تقديم المساعده الانسانيه دون
ضمانات لسلامته موظفها
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا عبر سكايب من
نيروبي كارل الشيكه بريق المتحدث باسم
المجلس النرويجي للاجئين في شرق افريقيا
سيد كارل اهلا بك معنا هذه التطورات هل
توحي او هذه الغده على الاقل وانت خللتها
بعض الاشتباكات وتم خرقها لبعض الفترات هل
تاملون في
تمديدها هذا وارد تعتقدون
الذين اضطروا للخروج من ديارهم وحتى اليوم
هناك اناس في الخرطوم
يشهدون عمليات خروجا كبيره بحثا عن مكان
امن لكن الوضع حتى الان يبقى متغيرا وغير
امن في الخرطوم وهذه هي المشكله بالنسبه
لمخالفه تلك الهدنه التي نتحدث عنها سيد
كارل انتم موجودون في السودان من قبل بدء
هذه الاشتباكات ومن قبل بدا هذه الحرب ان
صح التعبير
تراقبون وكذلك حتى تدعمون المخيمات الخاصه
باللاجئين هل تفكرون ان تطور الوضع باخلاء
العاملين التابعين المجلس النرويجي
للاجئين هل هناك شيء يحكى بهذا الصدد لان
هناك جهات امميه اختارت ان تبقي على
عميلها كيف الوضع في خصوصكم
هذه المساله سوف تكون
الاولويه بالنسبه لنا سوف نتخذ القرارات
مع تطور الاوضاع يوما تلو الاخر وفي جميع
الاحوال
نعلم ان المطار بات خارجا عن الخدمه في
الفتره الحاليه وليس من السهل ان نتحدث عن
خطه اجلاء الان وبصرف النظر عن ذلك حتى
وحتى اللحظه فان كافه
موظفين سواء من السودانيين او من الخبراء
لا يزالون على الارض لكن غالبيه موظفينهم
من السودانيين وسوف يبقون هناك
ويشعرون ينتظرون بقلق بالغ من اجل مساعدته
زملائهم
واخوانهم من السودانيين واللاجئين الاخرين
لكن دعوني اذكركم مره اخرى ان السودان كان
في وضع صعب سلفا وخاصه في دارف ور
حيث كل واحد من كل ثلاثه اشخاص بحاجه
لمساعده انسانيه قبل اندلاع تلك الصراعات
والان يمكن الحديث ان كل شخص بات بحاجه
لهذه المساعدات لانه نفذ منهم الغذاء
الغذاء والمياه
ووضع يبعث على الياس
خطه
لا تكون هي الاولويه بالنسبه لنا المهم هو
ان نحصل على دعم دولي يفرض على طرفي
الصراع من اجل وقف في هذا هذا القتال
وسماحي للوصول الى الاشخاص المحتاجين
ولابد لنا ان نفعل ذلك ضمن بيئه امنه
وسلام بحيث لا يتم استهداف زملائي هناك
نعم سيد قال حدثنا اكثر عن كيف تعملون
لادخال هذه المساعدات بمعنى ان المطار
الان خارج الخدمه وحضرتك تحدثت عن خطوره
هذا الوضع ولكن هل يمكن ان يكون هناك
ادخال للمساعدات برا مثلا مع من
تتناقشون حول هذه المساله خاصه وان
المساعدات تنقص داخل السوداني وان الوضع
كان حرج وزاد كارثيه مع انطلاق هذه
الازمه وحضرتك تحدثت عن تفاصيلها بالتالي
ما الذي تعملون عليه
لادخال هذه المساعدات في هذه الساعات خاصه
على التنسيق الذي سوف تتكلف به الامم
المتحده بصوره اساسيه واعلموا بان هناك
مفاوضات تجري في الفتره الحاليه ومناقشات
على قدم وساق
وطلبات من الدول المجاوره ان تبقي طرقاتها
مفتوحه نحو السودان
ومن خارج السودان بالنسبه لهؤلاء الذين
يفرون بحثا عن الامان والاف قد فعلوا ذلك
اتجهوا الى تشاد وفقا لتقارير من الامم
المتحده
لا توجد لدي اي تفاصيل ويتم العمل عليها
في الفتره الحاليه الوضع صعب لانه لا يوجد
لدينا مطار الذي يوصلنا الى العاصمه
وكافه النظم المساعده منهاره وهذا ينطوي
على تحديات كبيره في ايصال المساعدات من
طرفنا من قبل المنظمات الانسانيه وكذلك
ايضا الامدادات التجاريه التي لا بات
يتعذر عليها الوصول هناك سواء كان هناك
حرب من عدم لا بد من ايصالها للناس التي
الذين باتوا يفتقرون اليها وبدون هذه
الامدادات الطبيه فهناك حاجه ملحه لتلك
المواد الطبيه في المستشفيات فضلا عن نفاد
الوقود بابل بعض منها قد تم نهبها وسرقتها
وهذا ادى الى افتقار كبير وشحا في تلك
المواد في منظمات كثيره مثل منظمتنا وضعا
يبعث على الياس
ونعمل على التنسيق في هذا الشان الان اود
شكرا بالتوفيق لكم في باقي اعمالكم عبر
سكايب من نيروبي كارلي شيكامبريال المتحدث
باسم المجلس النرويجي للاجئين في شرق
افريقيا
ومشاهدينا
مواجهه البرهان وحمه العسكريه بارض
المعركه يقابلها تنافس اعلامي لا يقل حده
وفي وقت اكد احمد عدم التراجع عن اهدافه
على اعتبار ان ارض المعركه ستحدد كل شيء
لفت البرهان الى خروج جزء كبير من قوه
احمدتي عن السيطره قائد قوه الدعم السريع
اعتبر ان البرهان ليس مستعدا للانتقال
للحكم المدني لكن الاخيره اكد استئناف
الانتقال للمسار الديمقراطي بمجرد هزيمه
احمدتي اهداف احمدتي تشمل اعتقال البرهان
ومحاكمته اهداف تبين محاوله الدعم السريع
الاستيلاء على السلطه وفق البرهان حمدتي
شدد على عدم معارضه دمج قواته بالجيش من
حيث المبدا الجيش اكد الالتزام باستكمال
العمليه السياسيه وفق الاتفاق الايطالي
تراشق كلامي يستكمله احمدتي بتاكيد
انفتاحه على وقف اعمال العطف لكنه يؤكد
ايضا ان البرهان لن يتوقف فيما يتهم قائد
الجيش قوه
باعمال نهب الخرطوم ودارفور
مشاهدينا وسط ظلام الاقتتال هناك شعاع امل
في السودان في احد المستشفيات المتوقفه عن
الخدمه ولد طفل بعد ان تمكن طاقم طبي من
اجراء عمليه الولاده في ظل اضطرار الناس
للمكوث في منازلهم بسبب القصف العشوائي
المستمر
تنايا الحروب والمواجهه والاقتتال تبرز
اخبار باعثه الامل في نفوس الناس من
رحم المعاناه ولد طفل سوداني باحد
المستشفيات شجاعه كبيره من طواقم طبيه
متطوعه عرضت حياتها للخطر لاجراء هذه
الولاده المستعجله الفرح بهذا المولود لم
يكن عاديا ربما لانه يمثل ولاده السودان
جديد بعد نهايه الازمه في مخيلات
السودانيين على الاقل
مشاهدينا سنعود الى تغطيات التطورات وكذلك
الاشتباكات في داخل السودان ولكن كذلك
نذكر ببعض الاخبار
المتعلقه بكل تطورات التي يشهدها العالم
من خلال هذا الموجز
[موسيقى]
وفي هذا الموجز اكد الامين العام لحلف
شمال الاطلسي ياسر سبتمبرغ اثناء زياره
الى كيف ان اولويه الحلف تتمثل بضمان تغلب
اوكرانيا في الحرب على روسيا مضيفا انا
مستقبل اوكرانيا هو داخل العائله
الاوروبيه الاطلسيه وسيتم بحثه خطه
انضمامها للحلف خلال القمه التي ستعقد في
شهر يوليو
من جهته قال الرئيس الاوكراني
الوقت قد حان لي دعوتك للانضمام الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي واتخاذ القرار المناسب وشدد
ثلاث كيلدى لقائه في كاف على ضروره ان
تدعم كل الدول في الناتو انضمام اوكرانيا
الى صفوفه
افدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بتنفيذ 10
طلعات جويه لدعم وحدات الهجوم
فيسك وتدمير مقر قياده اوكرانيا على
الجبهه واشارت موسكو الى ان مدفعيه مجموعه
القوات الجنوبيه نفذت اربعا و60 مهمه قصفت
من خلالها مجموعه من المواقع ومنعت القوات
الاوكرانيه من القيام بهجوم مضاد
ابدت الاداره ذاتيه الكرديه التي تسيطر
على مناطق واسعه شمال وشمال شرق سوريا
ابدت موافقه مشروطه على لقاء الحكومه
السوريه للتواصل الى حل للازمه بينهما
الاداره الذاتيه اكدت في بيانها ضروره
التمسك بوحده الاراضي السوريه وتاسيس
نظاما اداريا سياسيا تعددي وتوزيع ثروات
والموارد الاقتصاديه بشكل عادل بين
المناطق السوريه بحسب قولها
شهدت مطارات هومبور ودوسلدو
من قبل عناصر الامن وذكر بيان صادر من
الجمعيه الالمانيه للموانئ الجويه ان
الاضرابه ينتج عنه الغاء حوالي 700 رحله
جويه في المطارات الثلاثه خلال اليوم وغدا
مضيفه ان حوالي
45.2 الف مسافر اضطروا الى تغيير خططي
سفرهم
مشاهدينا في نهايه هذه الساعه نشير الى
هذا العاجل بعد المملكه العربيه السعوديه
كذلك الامارات وقطر تعلينان غدا يوم عيد
فطر اعاده الله على كامل الامه العربيه
والاسلاميه بكل خير ان شاء الله هذه
التغطيه مستمره بعد قليل تلقاكم زميله
منتهى لاستكمال هذه التفاصيل ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات